- So if you could use
artificial intelligence
like to make your life
easier, what would you do?
'Cause mine would be
a masseuse. (laughing)
- That sounds kinda kinky.
- My body. (laughing)
I didn't go there.
- That's sounds all-purpose.
Listen, if it happens, it happens.
- Look, I'm not even,
I don't know how to talk about that.
I'm on daytime right now.
- I'm so sorry.
- No, no.
- It's too early.
- But no, but I will say, whatever.
But no, I find myself, I'm 40, like
and I find myself, I just,
I feel broken sometimes.
And I started Pilates
and did all the things.
A million things, but
like, I just feel broken.
- I love the way you say
Pilates with such disgust.
- [Kelly] I know, it's like
- You're like Pilates.
- I actually love Pilates, but I'm like,
it's just such a cliche.
You get to a certain age
and you're like, "I'm going to Pilates".
I'm like, you know, it's, yeah.
- You do the hand print.
- And I do the, yeah, stretch it out.
But it is wonderful.
But I find that my body always hurts.
So I'd get, I'd have a masseuse.
- You'd have a masseuse.
That's a really good idea.
- What about you? What would you do?
- I would, so even though
for my entire life,
three times a day, I've had to eat,
I forget every time
until it's like an hour
after I'm starving hungry.
- I do this.
- And I'm like, what is food?
What is food preparation?
What is planning? What's
the approach here?
Just someone to just
remind me that it's coming.
- I'm bad at that too.
I think you're too busy.
- Yeah, exactly. I get like
wrapped up in something.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And you're hungry.
So if I had, and then I mean,
if we're in a world where we're dreaming,
it's also preparing the food for me.
Because even sometimes
when you're that hungry
like a mac and cheese seems
kind of insurmountable.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Yes.
- It's hilarious to me
how many cooking demos I do on this show.
- [Allison] I know.
- And I'm not a cook.
- I know. I know.
- It's ironic. Really.
- I relate to you in that way.
- Oh yeah, me too.